— Dis donc Romain tu connais l'AVC toi ?
— Ben oui c'est au fond du couloir à droite !
— Attends tu viens vraiment de me faire la blague l'AVC - les WC ?
— Euh...
— Attends c'était pas une blague ?
— Si si...
L' AVC c'est un peu comme la PLS.
C'est rentré dans le langage courant, on fait des blagues dessus.
Mais en vrai tout le monde sait pas forcément ce que c'est.
Mais comme c'est quand même la première cause de handicap acquis.
En dehors des traumatismes genre accidents de la route.
Ça vaut la peine de se renseigner et surtout
de savoir repérer si quelqu'un en fait un devant vous.
Alors AVC ça veut dire :
C'est à dire qu'il y a un problème au niveau d'un vaisseau
chargé d’irriguer le cerveau et de lui apporter l'oxygène
et tout ce dont il a besoin pour fonctionner correctement.
Ça peut être un caillot qui bouche un vaisseau
et qui empêche le sang de passer.
Le caillot peut se former sur place ou à distance,
puis se balader dans la circulation jusqu'à venir se coincer
dans une artère du cerveau plus petite que les autres.
Dans ce cas-là, on parle d'AVC ischémique.
Et c'est le cas le plus fréquent.
Mais ça peut être aussi un vaisseau qui se met à fuir
ou carrément un vaisseau qui pête !
*bruit de pet*
"Haaaaaa !"
Romain, sérieux...
On parle alors d'AVC hémorragique.
Et là non seulement le sang n’irrigue plus la zone
mais en plus le saignement peut comprimer le cerveau.
Oui parce que quand on a un hématome au niveau du bras par exemple.
Comme la peau est élastique...
Ça gonfle mais ça comprime pas trop.
Le problème c'est qu'autour du cerveau, y'a la boite crânienne,
que la boite crânienne c'est de l'os,
que l'os c'est pas élastique et donc quand ça gonfle...
Ça comprime le cerveau.
Et le cerveau, être comprimé...
Il aime pas trop ça !
En plus quand le cerveau est abîmé.
Non seulement il a du mal à récuperer.
Mais comme c'est aussi le siège de fonctions super importantes.
Les conséquences peuvent être graves.
La gravité dépend de l'étendue de la zone qui n'est plus irriguée
et de sa localisation donc des fonctions qui sont atteintes.
Ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que plus vite un AVC est pris en charge.
Plus vite il est soigné et plus on diminue le risque de séquelles.
Ça fait un paquet de bonnes raisons de connaitre les signes pour le repérer.
Une des principales caractéristiques d'un AVC
c'est que ses signes apparaissent brutalement !
Comme un coup de tonnerre dans un ciel bleu.
Et sachez que la victime n'a pas forcement conscience de ses troubles.
Les signes les plus fréquents sont :
C'est le signe que les cellules nerveuses chargées de faire passer
les informations concernant les mouvements ont été touchées.
Si le côté gauche du cerveau est touché,
c'est la partie droite du corps qui en subi les conséquences.
Et inversement.
Parce que les faisceaux qui transmettent les informations se croisent
et changent de côté entre le cerveau et la moelle épinière.
Le visage devient asymétrique
avec notamment un côté de la bouche qui tombe.
Un des deux bras devient plus faible
avec une difficulté voire une impossibilité à le lever
ce qui peut aussi toucher la jambe du même côté.
Il y a aussi des troubles de la parole qui apparaissent.
La personne a du mal à parler, elle peut employer un mot pour un autre
ou prononcer des syllabes qui ne veulent rien dire
C'est le signe que les zones du langage
ou de la compréhension du langage ont été touchées.
D'ailleurs la victime peut aussi avoir du mal à comprendre ce qu'on lui dit.
Alors ça ce sont les signes principaux
mais ça peut aussi se manifester par :
Un gros mal de tête qui apparaît brutalement.
Des troubles de la vue comme la perte de la vision d'un œil
ou la vue qui se trouble.
Des fourmillements dans la moitié du corps.
Des troubles de l'équilibre et une démarche pas très stable.
Du coup comme en plus la personne parle bizarrement,
on peut penser qu'elle est bourrée...
Mais en fait non.
Ou alors peut être mais pas seulement !
Si vous avez un doute, je vous donne quelques trucs simples
pour vérifier qu'il s'agit bien d'un AVC.
Demandez à la victime de répéter une phrase simple
pour vérifier si elle a des troubles du langage.
Demandez-lui de sourire et de tirer la langue
pour vérifier si son visage devient asymétrique.
Demandez-lui de lever ses bras devant elle pendant 10 secondes.
Puis de serrer vos mains pour vérifier si elle a
moins de force d'un côté que de l'autre.
Vous pouvez aussi lui demander de lever ses jambes.
Mais dans ces cas-là faites la asseoir avant hein...
Non je vous jure, ça serait nulle comme blague.
C'est vraiment pas le moment.
Alors attention tous ces signes ne sont pas toujours présents
mais même si vous n'en repérez qu'un seul !
Et surtout si il est apparût brutalement.
Prévenez les secours !
En attendant qu'ils arrivent, rassurez la victime.
Bon alors ok, vu les circonstances ça va pas forcement être facile !
Mais si elle s'agite, elle risque de faire monter sa tension.
Et ça risque d’aggraver les choses.
Dites-lui que vous gérez, que les secours vont arriver.
Qu'elle va être prise en charge et qu'il faut qu'elle soit
le plus calme possible pour que tout se passe bien.
Si la victime est consciente, allongez-la dans une position confortable
avec un oreiller sous la tête.
Et notez toutes les informations importantes pour les secours
comme l'heure de début des troubles.
Si vous êtes chez elle, cherchez ces ordonnances
ou son dossier médical ça pourra aussi être très utile.
Ne la faite ni manger, ni boire
et ne la laissez pas prendre ses médicaments.
Si la personne est inconsciente, mettez la en PLS.
Alors on en a déjà parlé, mais n'hésitez pas à vous former.
Petite précision importante !
Parfois les signes peuvent être discrets
et la victime peut récupérer complètement dans la foulée.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un accident ischémique transitoire ou une
Ça veut dire qu'un vaisseau s'est bouché puis s'est débouché
mais ça reste une urgence.
Notamment parce qu'un AVC peut se constituer par la suite.
Donc appelez les secours.
Dans tous les cas si vous avez un doute.
Appelez le SAMU au 15
ou le numéro d'appel d'urgence européen au 112.
Vous tomberez sur des gens spécialement formés
qui vous diront exactement quoi faire.
Et n'ayez pas peur de mal faire.
La seule façon de mal faire à coup sûr, c'est de ne rien faire !
Voila DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui comme d'habitude...
Je vous mets des liens dans la description.
On se retrouve très vite
pour des nouvelles vidéos alors abonnez-vous
pour être sûr de rien louper hein.
D'ici là ce que je vous propose bah...
Mettez-vous bien et puis surtout portez-vous bien !